Ajax stands for asynchronous JavaScript
and XML a checked allows you to update
parts of a website without reloading the
entire page you can receive data from
the server instant data to a server in
the background here's an example so we
have the HTML code setup up here then we
have the JavaScript which has the Ajax
down here and then over here is is the
actual web page right on the side here
now let's see what happens when I push
this change content button see the text
is now changed to subscribe to the free
code camp YouTube channel that text is
actually nowhere in this code anywhere
because that text is coming from another
server I'm going to go through all this
coding detail but first I want to give
you an overview of the seven main steps
to ajax so the first step is that an
event occurs on a web page so that's
this see we have the button up here so
the event is when you hit the button the
second step is that an XML HTTP request
object is created by JavaScript now
that's right here it says new a XML HTTP
request the third step is that the xml
httprequest object sends a request to
the web server now that's the part down
here where we have the web server right
there and then we're going to send this
request down here X HTTP dot send the
next step is that the server processes
the request now that happens at the
server that we were making their quest
of then the fifth step is that the
server sends a response back to the web
page also at the other server the sixth
step is that the response is read by
JavaScript and if you look up here I can
explain this more in detail in just a
second but where it says this that
response text is where we get the
response from the server the seventh
step is that the proper action like a
page update is performed by JavaScript
so that's also in this line we're going
to update the HTML the website with the
JavaScript so now I'm going to go
through this code in detail I'm going to
start actually with this line right here
the actual file we're trying to get is
this one right here the HTTP colon slash
slash Karnes at CC slash code /h X
underscore example that txt now we also
have this other thing right
this work says cross-origin me now this
is a Poor's proxy which is a service
that allows developers to access
resources from other websites when they
would normally be a cross-origin error
now if I didn't have this right before
it I would get this error down here what
it says
it basically cannot load that file or it
says no access control origin headers
present on the requested resource
basically this is a security feature
where I'm on code pin right now you
cannot just easily pull files from
another web server now this is just a
basically a short-term solution using a
proxy like this it's a short-term
solution it's just a quick fix if you
want to try things out
the long-term solution would be to
update the htx s file on the server for
cons CC to allow cross origin requests
and then I can make this request without
adding the proxy at the beginning ok
let's go back to the rest of this code
here first of all you can see that in
the HTML when you click the button it's
going to call this function and that's
just right in the JavaScript then we're
going to create the XML HTTP request
we're going to create this object in
JavaScript now we're going to use this
property we're going to set this
property the onreadystatechange property
this property defines a function to be
called when the ready state property
changes and you can see the ready state
property right here we're going to use
that this ready state the ready state
property is going to be one of four
numbers 0 the request not initialized 1
server connection established two
requests received 3 processing requests
for requests finished and response is
ready so that's where we get to this
next line if this that rate state equals
equals 4 that means that the request is
finished and the response is ready and
this dot status equals equals 200 now
this is an HTML response so 200 means
okay another comment status would be 404
which means not found so 200 means that
the resource resource was found on a
server and what resource well we haven't
got to that yet but so this just means
if we got a good response in the
requests finished and it was found then
we can do something with the response so
go on to this line right here so we're
about to set something on the website
document dot get element by ID so the
idea is right here ID equals demo we're
going to set the innerhtml
that means we're going to change the
HTML between the tags that have the ID
demo and we're going to set this text to
this dot response text this dot response
text just returns the data as a string
from the from the server we could use
this dot response XML if we want XML
returned let's do another example of
this I'm going to reset this it starts
with let Ajax changes text click change
content and then we've just gotten this
information from another server and if
we go down here the open function is
where we specify what file or resource
we are requesting but this does not
actually request it yet here we use get
we can also use post if you are sending
a large amount of data to the server or
sending user input you should use post
here but otherwise you use you should
usually use get and then we actually put
where the resources located what website
we're trying to get something from and
this last thing true this is for whether
or not the request is asynchronous you
almost always want true for asynchronous
so you can execute other scripts while
waiting for a server response now this
last thing right here the HTTP dot send
function is where we actually send the
request to the server so this just means
do everything we set up to do these
previous things with the X HTTP object
and then after the request changes the
ready state it will call this function
this was just a brief introduction to
ajax if you want to learn more check out
the links in the description thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good